[Music]
let's talk about pink okay everyone is
still talking about her inspiring sweets
to her daughter willow at MTV VMAs so
here's what we learned
clearly it's family first in the heart
household
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
how proud of your mommy are you you my
darling girl are beautiful pinks and
powering love letter to six-year-old
daughter Willow and seeing their
affectionate bond in the audience was
everything willows first et red carpet
interview was at the 2016 Alice Through
the Looking Glass premiere they would
like to know what you thought of mommy's
performance today great it was good like
like awesome good or like kind of good
it's clear Pink's priority is
cultivating willow self-confidence and
independence
she's not very impressed by me which I
like we hear you right you can do it
yourself why would you be impressed
pink and husband of 11 years carry heart
also have a very giggly eight-month-old
son Jameson this summer pink shared
their life on the road as she toured the
festival circuit did your tooth but this
picture-perfect family unit did not come
without a fight sometimes I wanna slap
you on your whole face pink proposed to
the motocross racer in 2005 they married
the next year but in 2008 they split up
for nearly a year after reconciling and
becoming parents pink wrote one of the
realest songs about marriage true love
hates you so much they give my speech
I feel like you have fought for each
other you've earned each other you've
earned this or each other we'd fight
each other a mixed bag that's the love
though right right good
that's what we love about them though
they tell you the truth now pink has
even more to celebrate her music sales
yeah they have gone up 70% after her VMA
performance
[Music]
you